The level of emotional pain we feel is directly related to the meaning we give an experience.
This video explores the meaning we place on failure.
What does failure mean to you?
Does it trigger any of the three universal fears that we share?
I am not enough, I don't belong, and I'm not loved.
The worlds elite in their field have a very different relationship to failure.
We have identified three key differences that are critical to know.
Key number one, they often don't see failure as failure.
Many of our champions do not even register what we call failure as failure.
In fact, their minds are so relentless and focused on their vision that they simply filter
failure as a stepping stone to achieving their desired outcome.
Thomas Edison, the inventor of the electric light bulb, when questioned about his many
failures responded by saying, I have not failed 700 times, I have succeeded, improving that
those 700 ways will not work.
When I have eliminated the ways that will not work, I will find the way that will work.
We can clearly see that Thomas is seeing his failures as feedback.
The meaning he is placing on his failures is constructive, and because of this mindset,
he succeeded in reaching his goal.
Carol Dweck, author of Mindset, The New Psychology of Success, has proven through her extensive
research in high schools that when we focus on growing and learning, our fear around failure
radically drops and our confidence to achieve results increases dramatically.
In fact, some of the schools that followed these key lessons experienced their students'
grades, moving from the bottom of their district to the top position.
Wow!
When we see challenges as on the way and not in the way, our results skyrocket.
No failure, only feedback works.
Key number two, champions use the painful experiences.
If the world's best do see their failures as failure and experience emotional pain,
they allow themselves to feel that pain and learn from it.
To use a metaphor, they take the lead, pain, extract the learning elements from the experience
and turn it into gold.
Excellence.
They choose to use that setback or loss as a powerful source of inspiration.
And as they do this, they are reframing the meaning of that experience.
Once the meaning is truly changed, our experience also changes.
Tip number three, they start with the outcome in mind.
They have already made up their minds to make progress and therefore, regardless of what
happens along the way, they take the best from each outcome.
They have already given themselves permission to be their best.
They have chosen to play to win from the start and this momentum keeps them strongly remaining
above the line as they move through the many challenges they face along the way.
In the words of the great Tony Robbins, there is no failure, only results.
What Tony is teaching us here is that when we remove all the stories and meanings we
place on our outcomes, we can simply see that a result has occurred.
And that result can either be what we want or what we don't want.
For Thomas Edison's response, his failure was valuable feedback that helped him succeed.
Without those failures, he would not have reached his goal.
Choosing the meaning you place on your failures and what parts of your failures you choose
to focus on will radically affect your confidence moving forward.
Congratulations, you have completed your overview on No Failure Only Feedback.